recording in progress very curious
because
this program is offered essentially
worldwide and we'd like to know
where we have visitors from today
how are you
um and Erie Pennsylvania for the folks
in India can you tell us what part what
town what uh Province state
Bangalore
Paraguay wonderful
South Africa
hello
so our audience is uh
heavily from India today but we do have
folks from Nigeria South Africa Paraguay
and South America
so welcome to everyone
Japan I think that's the first time I've
seen someone join one of our webinars
from Japan so very welcome to you
and let's
Canada let's get started
China welcome
so
I'm going to switch over the chat to
um this host and panelists
but if you continue to put your
information in we'll be able to see it
here pressure Tom and I and let me
introduce myself I'm Stuart Creek and
with simply learn we are the delivery
partner with Caltech for this program
the postgraduate program in cloud
computing
and
Persia time here is one of our senior
instructors I'll introduce him in a
moment
okay
we'll talk about your cloud computing
careers we're going to ask you a few
questions along the way about you and
the audience so please watch out for
those polls we'll
um talk about how Caltech Center for
technology and management education
can help you become job ready for cloud
computing we'll mention some learner
outcomes and we'll go over enrollment
steps
oh gives you a q a with the Persia Tom
toward the end of the session so please
put your questions for him into the Q a
function within Zoom that way we'll keep
them separate from the chat and we'll be
able to find them more easily
so let me start with a question for our
audience
and this question is
how much experience do you have
in the workplace are you currently
studying for your degree or are you in
the work of course and if so how long
and I'll just leave this open for about
another 10 seconds that's a pretty
straightforward question
so please let us know
and I'll close the poll in three
two one
so about a quarter of our audience are
currently studying for the degree and uh
and the rest of your fairly evenly
divided between people who are fairly
new in the workplace and people who have
more than five years experience that
helps Orient us to who's here
what your concerns will be
and please put those
questions into the Q a box so that we
can address them in the Q a uh simply
learn is the world's number one online
boot camp this is the reason why Caltech
chose us to help them deliver this
program we have been doing this for 13
years and have helped 5 million
Professionals in 150 countries upskill
in digital economy we specialize in
digital skills and we deliver these
schooling programs
solely online so you are able to access
them from anywhere you have an internet
connection in a web browser and
we're as I said extremely proud to be
working with Caltech on this and in
several of their other Skilling programs
so
uh Persia time I would love for you to
introduce yourself tell us about your
background
and maybe a little bit about how you got
to where you are in cloud computing sure
thank you through it yeah buddy
so yes good morning and good evening
everyone out here yeah so uh I'm Dr
purushottam and I'm working as an
assistant professor in information
technology department in Sri ramdev Baba
College of engineering and management
nagpur Maharashtra India and I
specialize in cloud computing Microsoft
Azure AWS and operating systems I am a
Google Scholar certified trainer
Microsoft certified trainer AWS
certified trainer corporate trainer
three times certified on AWS Microsoft
Azure certified AWS certified trainer I
sure said if Microsoft Azure certified
trainer guys and I've done my PhD in
cloud computing in resource scheduling
in cloud from vit Vellore and
um
he also uh I've been associated with
Caltech through simply learn
from quite some years and also
associated with many iits in India for
delivering their uh programs in cloud
computing and
um
yeah so uh I started my journey in Cloud
way back in 2015 and then I did my
research also in cloud and so that's how
I am into cloud and doing great here so
uh has delivered multiple corporate
trainings with multiple consultancies
um that includes a lot of them like
Vodafone UK Mercedes Benz RND clients
and there are many and have delivered
trainings in across India outside of
India yeah so uh really passionate about
cloud computing in into cloud from quite
some time
thank you thank you thank you and I
appreciate that and
let's talk about careers in cloud
computing because that's I think why the
folks in our audience are here today
and so Cloud really has
you know from something that didn't
exist 20 odd years ago
um
it's become essentially an uh
integral part of all of our Lives not
just the economy but our personal lives
is that not true
exactly yeah
yes
yes so of course yeah go ahead so so can
you kind of take us
through what
what cloud does for us today what what
the technology you know starting off as
shared Computing how it's changed and
how it uh
what the kinds of services are that the
cloud provides to people
today yeah
sure so uh it all started with a great
Computing distributed computing and then
uh we have emerged to cloud computing so
see basically uh whatever we do it on
the on-premises
um let it be a server databases your
network so everything you have it in the
cloud everything okay and the best part
is that in Cloud
um there is nothing called as capital
expenditure uh I'll just give you an
example let's say if you want to have
your own data center or your servers on
premises then you would order them and
then they will come to your place you
will install security updates on them
you will patch those servers
um so it would take like 10 to 12 days
to have your server up and running in
Cloud you can just create a server that
is a virtual server in in matter of
minutes and plus you don't even have to
own that physical infrastructure you
don't even have to own that physical
server okay on which your virtual server
will be getting created uh so there is
no capital expenditure which you used to
have in the on-premises plus there is no
like uh there's just operational
expenditure and plus um you can you can
you can create your servers from any
point in time in the day or night
sitting at any place across the globe
you can create your server at at any
different location and can start working
on it and it has the great advantage of
elasticity also like
um if you have created a server and you
are using it just for two hours and then
you feel like you don't need it anymore
you just terminate it and you just have
to pay for two hours correct so that's
the best part of it so
still excuse me sorry for that sure go
ahead so yeah so that's the best part of
it correct so uh guys and uh apart from
that see uh it's written says so uh even
like uh you can create servers in Cloud
you can use it in an infrastructure as a
service manner or SAS based manner or or
Pass based manner so if you use it in a
platform as a service manner so then you
don't even have to manage those virtual
servers also like you can just
concentrate on your business like let's
say Netflix Netflix hosted on AWS
correct Amazon so they are just uh
taking care of their business uh like
the entertainment business uh so if you
host your uh infrastructure in a Pass
based manner so you don't even have to
manage your infrastructure and that
would be managed by the cloud provider
so you can just concentrate on your core
business so yeah it has become the
backbone of digital economy uh because
there is no capital expenditure so not
even just the startups uh but even the
established companies are moving towards
cloud guys because
um of no capital expenditure because of
great security and because of global
reach as well and there are so many
features for anything that you ask or
whether it is iot machine learning or
anything anything anything yeah so
um it's a great Boon to be in the cloud
era yeah I mean the
[Music]
even if you aren't an entrepreneur or a
corporation that's using the cloud to
deliver your services we all are
familiar with how the cloud empowers us
with our mobile devices
[Music]
um with things like the cloud storage of
our
photographs and other data it's
interesting that apple
apparently recently said that they're
not going to continue to offer free
cloud storage of of photos and apple
photo service
um
it kind of speaks to how big of a
Heart Of Our Lives it is that so many
people are upset about that
um but you kind of all assume that we're
going to get these kinds of things for
free because cloud has made it so
available to to everybody and you can
see here from the statistics that the
spending on cloud computing is jumping
into the range of
total gross national product of small
countries
half a trillion dollars on software as a
service
looking at public Cloud spending uh
going almost to three-quarter trillion
dollars in 2025
worldwide so this is a
huge and growing
industry and
there's really no reason to think that's
going to slow down is there
it's going to even increase more
um we look at different potential career
paths for people who come into the into
cloud computing and you know what's the
kind of entry point that somebody
would would start in this field and and
where are the places they could go
yeah
which of these roles is the place where
people would most likely to start yeah
and where would they go from there sure
right so uh when you are into Cloud so
initially I would suggest you would
start as a cloud engineer okay uh so if
you have got uh some good knowledge on
cloud uh let's say the basic
certifications like practitioners in AWS
practitioner or Azure fundamentals you
can start your role as a cloud engineer
and then if you are more focused towards
the development part of the things if
you are interested in coding part of the
things then you can opt for becoming a
cloud developer so um like you can go
for uh the subsequent certifications
like uh from my sure you can go with uh
ez204 that is azure developer associate
or AWS developer associate and then you
can become a cloud developer as well in
those domains um then if you are if you
are not towards coding side maybe or if
you are if you are if you are an
experienced guy and you're working on on
a on an architect role or maybe uh like
having good number of years of
experience so you can um actually uh
become a cloud architect and for that uh
you you have good certifications in in
AWS as
um Azure AWS architect uh Solutions
architect associate and solutions
architect professional
um which actually I've done and then in
Azure side you have Azure uh architect
uh as well uh that is ez305
okay
um right guys so then apart from that
there are specialty certifications also
in cloud like if you are on the database
end
um so you can go for I mean if you are
interested in the back end stuff and a
database part of it so you can become a
database administrator okay
um and there are good number of
certifications for database specialty in
AWS in Azure correct um then apart from
that
uh uh if you are a security uh guy if
you are interested in the security part
of the things if you are interested in
cryptography network security so of
course uh it is also in huge demand you
can become a cloud security engineer and
um uh so you again have good number of
certifications related to that like AWS
security specialty associate
um yeah our network engineer you can
become with that then apart from that
uh if you are into the Automation and
automation side uh you can go and become
a devops engineer wherein you can you
can create your complete pipeline that
is a continuous integration continuous
deployment pipeline okay cicd pipeline
into Cloud so like you can do it with
your open source tools uh like Jenkins
Maven terraform in the same way uh Cloud
also provides its own proprietary tools
as well like AWS has its own tools like
code commit code deploy code Pipeline
and so on similarly Azure also has has
it correct so the point is guys um you
can get into all these roles and for
getting into all these roles you should
have good knowledge around these roles
and there are specific certifications
from different Cloud providers for the
said roles uh you can go and I mean you
can study and clear those kind of
certifications and it becomes uh very
much possible for you to get into these
roles after that
um so and and just to put uh some what
more into it like um you can like
today's era of multi-clouds okay so uh
basically if you want to become a cloud
engineer or Cloud developer or Cloud
architect or any of these roles
um it is always preferred uh that you
should have knowledge on multi-cloud
platforms not just single Cloud platform
like if I talk about the public Cloud
platforms then the market leaders as per
the Gartner which is the research
organization so AWS uh and Azure uh even
gcp are are the leading players in the
market okay so
um it's better uh if you want to be into
Cloud you should run you should learn
not just about one Cloud platform uh but
you should learn at least about two
Cloud platforms like at least AWS and
Azure and if you are into that then
there are good uh like um you have good
scope of getting into these roles
because there is a reason behind that
like let's say if any company wants to
to move towards Cloud so the let's say
the public Cloud so the first choice for
them is uh let's say AWS or Azure so
they'll use some services from AWS some
from Azure some from another Cloud
platform so that way multi-cloud is the
era and if you know about these Cloud
platforms uh like AWS Azure gcp the
market leaders so you have a good future
ahead into the cloud domain I would say
yeah thank you very much it takes us
through you know the kinds of places you
can go in this career you look at Cloud
developers Cloud Engineers uh
with salary ranges that are average
around 10 lock per year on up to 22.
these are just figures from glassdoors
so these are surveys of salaries in
India
um and you look at Cloud Architects
where you could move into your career as
you gain experience and more skills
20 lock average up to 33 are do you see
these as as bear numbers or are you
looking are you seeing uh different
numbers out in the marketplace
I have seen people getting more than
what the numbers are mentioned here uh
like one of my friends
um he's in Amazon he's an architect okay
and uh is he's with good experience and
he's earning around 60 lakhs per annum
yeah yeah so these numbers are actually
like I've seen uh people doing more than
these what the numbers are shown here
yeah
um and it it is interesting because even
if you look at Glassdoor and you see
these ranges that top out at these
levels uh then you look at the job
offerings or job uh openings that are
there and the salary ranges that are
listed uh sometimes are well above these
so again this is a a career field where
people can
quickly move into a very lucrative
good paying career so to do that you've
got to have
the kinds of skills that range across
all the different aspects you talked a
little bit about the the notion that
somebody who wants to be a cloud
practitioner should understand
not just one of the platforms but
several of them in the same way how
important is it to understand all of the
different aspects of cloud computing
managing and deploying Cloud Solutions
yeah so see uh basically if you want to
be a cloud practitioner so you don't
have to be the master of all these
skills but then you have to be Jack of
all like uh you should be aware about
the different services that are there
but as you go ahead and you become
either a developer I mean you go for
developer certification or architect
level certification then you deep dive
into the things and you get more
understanding on these things okay uh so
uh more Hands-On more understanding on
to the things but yes if you want if you
want to be a practitioner also so yes
the high level aspects of all these
Services of all these domains is a must
you should be knowing about it so
cloud provider selection of course if
your company wants to move towards Cloud
so which Cloud they should opt for for
which particular service service okay so
um you should give them the optimum
choice of which uh which cloud provider
selection you should be going for and
then of course for application migration
so you can move all of your on-premises
applications towards Cloud there are
different services like in uh you have
um in Azure you have app migration uh
then in AWS also you have the service
for that then uh of course for testing
also you have different things so you
should know how to do performance
testing Cloud workloads identity access
management so this is interesting
identity access management specially for
the administrators so if if if if your
company is in the cloud and you have
multiple employees working in your
organization and so you want to have
multiple accounts for your multiple
employees in your root account in AWS uh
so that can be done you can create
multiple IM users with identity and
access management and you can grant them
different policies different roles so
that they are just being assigned the
access to the services that they need
let's say for example if a person is
working as a network administrator uh if
an employee is working as a network
admin so he should be given access to
own only the networking services and not
maybe the access to database services so
you can just grant them those kind of
privileges okay uh so so you need to
follow the principle of least privilege
here like whatever the role a particular
person is performing in the organization
give him the access to those many
resources only not less than that not
more than that so that can be very
easily done with identity access
management so your administrators play a
vital role uh to to learn this service
and to use it that way correct and then
you have Auto scaling so Auto scaling of
course we all know like uh the load on
uh the websites normally is not the same
let's take an example of Flipkart Amazon
so during their sale days guys the load
on their website is not the same it
shoots up okay so like Amazon's great
Indian sale Flipkart big billion days so
let's say if that website Amazon website
is running on hypothetically let's say
100 servers so during sale days when the
load increases on their website let's
say for all the hundred servers are more
than 90 percent utilized so then what
should happen and more number of servers
should be created because if that
doesn't happen guys then what will
happen the website performance will go
down or the website May crash also so
the point is that more number of servers
should be created and they should be
created automatically without user
intervention without a manual
intervention they should be created
automatically to handle the additional
load okay so that can be done with auto
scaling feature in AWS in Azure plus
when the when the when the when the
demand is less when the sale days are
over so those additional servers may not
be required because the load on the
servers is less let's say less than 10
10 or 20 CP utilization on them so those
additional servers should be
um deleted or terminated as well correct
so that can also be done in an automated
manner with auto scaling and so that
reduce on your cost so you don't have to
pay for them when not required and when
you need it it would be Auto created so
of course uh these are the aspects that
you can do actually by learning are
getting into cloud how you can do all
these things in Cloud out there apart
from that here disaster recovery so an
important aspect Disaster Recovery um
let's say if your website is hosted just
in uh in some region on a server out
there and God forbids guys uh if if
there is a disaster in that region so if
the entire region goes down then your
server your data would also go down but
in Disaster Recovery what you do is you
replicate your data in across the
regions in different regions okay so
even if one region is down it's not
working still you can have access to
your data to your servers from another
region okay
so that's the best part of it so of
course there are good services like you
have Azure Recovery Services walled in
in fact in AWS you have cross Regional
application with S3 buckets so those of
course uh you you learn when you when
you when you study into Cloud correct
um then of course web services and API
application programming interface to uh
to take care of interacting with the
cloud and then web services with which
you can you can host your web servers in
Cloud then uh Cloud migration and
deployment so almost everything you can
migrate it into cloud like let's let's
say if it's a server migration database
migration app migration so all of that
you can actually migrate it into Cloud
there are multiple services available
for that as well for databases again it
supports so so when I talk about
database guys um gone are the days when
you used to have just the uh I mean a
traditional relational database only
that that that that takes care of all
your needs like one one size fits all
that is not quite the case right now you
have different types of data like you
have relational data for that you have
relational databases taking care of you
have no SQL data like without relations
like nosql means spreadsheet data Excel
data right so you have no SQL databases
that are taking care of those relation
wherein you don't have the restriction
on the schema you can easily change the
schema plus you have uh like uh let's
say take the example of Facebook so you
have different relations in Facebook
like if you are friends to somebody it
will give you the suggestion like you
can be you can make friends to this
person also because he's sent to uh your
friend so those are the graph based
relations so those are called as graph
DB so for graph DB again you have the
good services in the cloud like you have
Amazon Neptune for nosql databases you
have Cosmos DB in Azure you have uh
dynamodb needed AWS for for relational
databases you have RDS relational
database service in AWS you have MySQL
in Azure correct so there there are many
different types of databases available
guys correct
so the point is that
uh
when I talk about database management
it's not just about one type of data for
all different types of data you have
Solutions in the cloud for Big Data also
you have okay so that are all there for
analysis purpose as well you have big
data then multi-cloud as I already told
you multi-cloud uh deployment it
supports you can even like you can move
your data from one Cloud platform to
another Cloud platform you can connect
your network from One Cloud to another
Cloud platform with VP and v-net Gateway
service okay so that's all possible and
when I talk about storage services so
very important storage Services comes in
all different certifications that you
would appear in any of these public
Cloud platforms so the point is in
student services you have a solution for
object-based storage like if you want to
store your images audios videos
object-based data you have a solution
for that like S3 bucket in AWS blog blob
in Azure then if you have
um blog based data wherein you can
install your operating system files or
or your softwares correct so you have
block based storage devices so for that
the solution is elastic block storage in
AWS you have page blobs in a sure
correct so that is there plus you have
shared storage like one storage you want
to share it with multiple virtual
machines so you can use that as well for
that you have EFS and AWS for Linux
machines Associates storage FSX for
Windows machines FSX Lester fast storage
for Linux machines then you have
in in in Azure also uh file sharing
Azure for the shared storage of course
yes so yeah so these skills you'll learn
and you should be knowing about it then
yeah so this is
from that discussion we get the the idea
that
there's an awful lot to know about cloud
um that you need to be aware of all
these different aspects of it as you
said at the beginning it's not
necessarily that you to be a
Master practitioner in each of these
areas but knowing about all of these
areas and how they interact uh will make
you effective if you choose to design it
and limit a Cloud solution or if you
choose to specialize in something like
um cloud devops and
particular things like Cloud security
you'll you'll understand all the other
aspects that you need to know oops going
wrong way
so let's uh ask another question from
our audience and this one is uh
presumably you have looked at various
programs because you're interested in
qualifying for a cloud computing career
what has stopped you what are the things
that have been lacking in programs that
you've looked at
so is it because you haven't found
something that can cover the kinds of
skills and tools comprehensively as
Richardson described uh is it because
you don't feel you would get the
Practical experience and experience
examples that you use to show your new
skills
because you find the learning style
difficult with other programs or is it
because you don't feel that you have the
time to pursue this in your work
schedule
and I'll leave this open just for
another five seconds
please hit the submit button
and I'm closing the poll now
and for today's audience all four
reasons are are very important um
with the Practical exposure and the
scheduling being the most important of
the group but I see that there's a
balance of concerns about the different
areas so
let's talk about
this program
and this program
is again industry aligned learning path
got integrated labs and Hands-On
projects for practical experience online
live virtual classrooms so that you're
learning with the help of an instructor
so that you can interact with your peers
ask them
what did you get from this lesson or how
did you approach this problem and then
being able to work on your own schedule
and this program is the postgraduate
program in cloud computing
from caltex Center for technology and
management education so it's an 11 month
program
ask people to do about 10 to 15 hours a
week between the live classes and the
work that you do to prepare for those
classes
doing
classes precious time when you're doing
a class with live environment you're
taking
the Learners through these Hands-On
exercises code samples and not only
demonstrating them but actually having
them do that with you is that correct
exactly correct yeah so I believe in um
like we do it along uh for the for the
Learners normally do it many of the
exercises along with me okay and apart
from that the Hands-On is not just like
uh normal uh simple Labs but we do
scenario based Labs wherein uh you get
an output and you come to understand why
you got that and you feel good about it
because this is end-to-end things that
we do scenario based labs and that can
actually help you in your real time
working also so there are two aspects uh
getting you prepared for from the
certification point of view but more
than that it is uh like how it would
help you in your real time working
um when you are into projects when you
are working on that technology correct
and the classes are anyways like eight
live classes are eight hours I think a
week is it is correct and then the other
time um they can spend uh learning the
self-learning videos and preparing on
what has been discussed in the live
classes correct right and the platform
is available to Learners 24x7 so
aside from the scheduled class times
where you meet with uh your instructor
and your and your fellow Learners
um the rest of the week anytime that you
have
available to you to do your additional
projects Labs uh preparation that's a
you can do that at any time day or night
um you have the platform that supports
uh your Virtual Lab environment so you
don't have to build your own private lab
or you don't have to subscribe to cloud
computing accounts this is all built
into the program and the platform so
that everything you need to have is
available to you victim will be able to
share that with us in a bit um
at the end of this process
once you've completed the core courses
uh and the final project you will
receive a certification from Caltech
and you will have over 40 Projects in
your uh
portfolio things that you have done
during the course that you will then be
able to show off to other people uh if
you are in a
history or an environment where you need
to provide proof of continuing education
Caltech can issue you up to 30 CEUs
continuing education units so that you
can use that to prove your work to your
employer or to any regulatory agency
that might license you
there's also membership in their online
Caltech ctma Circle which is online
Alumni Association for people who have
taken this type of
a program from Caltech ctme whether it's
cloud computing data science artificial
intelligence you get to to network with
those people and Caltech runs special
events online for their Caltech ctmu
Circle we also run an event with them
for the convocation that recognizes you
for completing the program so you'll be
able to invite your friends and family
to see you being recognized by name for
receiving your certificate and finally
simply learn offers an additional
benefit which is job assist and I will
describe that in a little bit but all of
these come to you
from completing this program
let's talk a little bit about Caltech
Caltech has a Justified worldwide
reputation it's been around for 130
years
it's a private school it's not part of
the University of California system or
California State University system uh
it's an independent Institution
uh number of people have won Nobel
prizes for the research they've done
there
a number of people who won Nobel prizes
else for work done elsewhere have come
to Caltech to continue their work and
Caltech
leads in many many different areas of
Technology research and development
for example they run the jet propulsion
laboratory for NASA which means that
they do in fact build the satellites and
deep space probes that Nasa uses and
launches for research
um Caltech consistently ranks in one of
the top five universities worldwide it
is one of the
uh
most dense concentrations of brilliant
people in the world
and so having this name on your CV is
something that people will recognize
it has a worldwide poll
this particular program requires you to
have a bachelor's degree with at least
50 percent marks do not have to have a
bachelor's degree in technology
programming you don't have to have a
programming coding background
um the this program
doesn't require work experience but work
experience is always helpful
in these types of things so for those of
you with work experience
that kind of adds to your ability to
understand how Cloud fits into the work
environment to the Enterprise and also
gives you
context for how you would use it in your
industry
um so person time you work with people
who come in from a non-programming
background how
how is it that they can absorb the
skills that they need to be proficient
in this technical field
yeah sure uh so see basically
um programming background is not a must
if you want to be in Cloud there are few
prerequisites uh that if you have it's
an added Advantage the prerequisites
being uh some uh basic knowledge in
operating systems uh networking okay I
would suggest uh even in databases part
but even if you don't have it uh like so
uh in simply learn here uh I personally
take it up from the basics okay and
apart from that you are being given uh
some some initial courses also that um
like some initial knowledge that you can
go with plus I take it up from the
basics and the programming or coding
background is not a must here uh see if
you want to be a developer uh in in in
in Cloud let's say if you want to go
with is it 204 Azure developer associate
or AWS developer associate then you
should be having a good programming
background but then that is not a must
skill okay because
um you can be in Cloud you can do very
well in Cloud even if you don't have a
programming background there because
there are different roles Okay so
you can be an architect you can be an
administrator you can be a cloud
engineer okay and these all uh things
you can be into without having a good
programming background uh if even if you
are from non-programming background you
can really uh Excel all in all these
domains okay so it's not a thing like if
you're thinking that if you are from a
non-programming background maybe it is
difficult to get into it that is not at
all the case because in Cloud it has
letters for everybody and anybody like
you can be a DB engineer you can be a
network engineer you can be an architect
you can be a admin associate of course
programming uh background is not
required that much there uh yeah if you
want to be a developer uh then of course
programming background is required yes
yeah
let's talk about how the program
prepares people in
getting them ready how is structured and
how it takes you through this process so
start with the orientation session which
is basically to help people understand
how to use this online platform where to
find their courses what they can expect
from the curriculum
um generally about a two-hour
orientation session that gets you ready
to start your classes and when you start
moving into classes there's the Three
core modules before the Capstone can you
take us through that and why they're
structured in this way
yes sure right so see when you start
it's like uh first of all you have the
orientation section which is from a
professor from Caltech and then
um like see you have to get into the
cloud Journey so as I told you
multi-cloud uh is what you should be
learning so that's why um in this
program we are making the Learners not
just to be good in one public Cloud
platform but in multiple Cloud platforms
so we start our journey with AWS and the
first course uh after the orientation
program that you opt for is AWS
Solutions architect associate okay in
that you have the concepts plus the
Hands-On
um maybe scenario based Labs on AWS
Solutions architect Associates so that
gets you prepared to work in AWS domain
and to get prepared for the
certification on AWS Solutions architect
associate once you finish that uh then
we touch the other Cloud platform that
is the Microsoft Azure Cloud platform
which are nothing but the market leaders
both AWS and Azure so in Azure we take
up two courses basically so we first opt
for the admin uh Azure administrator
because let me tell you there are a lot
of Hands-On activities in Azure
administrator that one should go into
okay so that is termed as az104 and um
again we will have this Azure
administrator course for 40 to 50 years
and uh um once you complete this once
you're good into this uh then you get
into uh the architect certification on
Azure that is designing Microsoft Azure
infrastructure Solutions
ez305 and in this uh particular uh
course you learn about how you can
design your Solutions in in Microsoft
Azure which services are useful so
basically here you make the design
decisions let's say if there are a
number of services to do a particular
task so which one will fit uh which one
will suit you
um based on your organization
requirements based on the budgets and
the different aspects which service you
should go for so you get familiar to
that you will be able to select that in
your organization correct
um yeah so that is what we go into and
once you have these compulsory courses
done
um cleared all of them like uh completed
in the sense you submit the project
anyways we'll come to that during the uh
LMS demo part so once you have those
clear these uh courses in simply learn
by completing the projects and
attendance criteria then
um you can actually go and get into the
cloud computing Capstone project again
that could be mentored by an instructor
and once you complete that cloud
computing Capstone project then you
receive the equated uh certificate from
Caltech University
and uh that is the postgraduate program
in cloud computing and apart from that
after completing all these courses you
will get the certificate from Simply
learn and the criteria for completing
the courses are you have to complete the
project assignments plus the attendance
you'll have to maintain correct um
that's how it goes through plus there
are the elected sections as you can see
out there so Guys these electors are not
the compulsory one so if you have to
clear this program uh well these
completing these electives are not
compulsory but if you want to learn more
of course you can opt for any or all of
these electives of course you can go for
it
and so uh in that you can go in devops
on cloud Google Cloud platform architect
training also and you will see third
Cloud included here AWS data migration
systems associate
um AWS developer associate uh Microsoft
Azure uh uh developer associate that is
either 204 and then the Caltech cloud
computing academic Master Class also
that would be conducted by the
professors in Celtics from Caltech right
so yes uh you can opt for those also
right
they're all included in the cost of the
program so there's no extra cost to take
any of the electives as as you just said
purchased on people can take uh any one
or all of them at their own discretion
based on their interests and and their
amount of time that they have available
so that's a good way for you to
essentially kind of customize the
program to your particular needs
um so during this program as you
mentioned people are using these
different tools and dozens more that um
they need to be able to use for the
exercises for the projects and
as they're using them they're not only
hearing about them or watching you
demonstrate them they're actually
employing the tools on their own
uh Virtual Lab environment right
yeah yeah so correct of course
um so uh
they just demonstrate all of these like
uh when they when they'll be doing the
labs or when they'll be doing the
projects um they come across all these
services and it's not just the
instructor showing them but they'll be
doing it as well and they'll be making
use of all the different services to
create
um I mean uh to to accomplish their labs
to complete their Labs plus the project
requirement okay so like you have uh if
I would put some light on few of the
services that are being mentioned here
so like if you want to create servers in
cloud like say AWS you have Amazon ec2
service elastic compute Cloud which is
offered in an infrastructure as a
service mode IES Okay then if you want
to have a nosql database in AWS you can
go for Amazon dynamodb service that can
give you that then if you want to create
a serverless application like uh when
you want to just write a function uh by
by putting your code there and you don't
want to create yourself the
infrastructure the server so you can
just make use of AWS Lambda that is a
serverless application that then you
don't have to provision the server but
the underlying infrastructure the
servers that are required that would be
created and managed by Amazon at the
back end so for you it is serverless in
nature
and then of course if you want to have
object-based storage uh you want to
store your audios videos files raw data
in in let's say AWS so you have Amazon
S3 service that is simple storage
service to do that then of course on the
Azure end um everything that you use is
uh like or you create the resources in
Azure resource manager model Okay then
if you want to have your if you have
Loosely coupled applications
if you have microservices these
applications small applications so you
can
um host them I mean uh or you can create
them using the container service for
that you learn the containers and
kubernetes in the cloud of course they
are included in the architect
certification see continuous kubernetes
part okay so that you can opt for
um then of course that is there in Azure
and there are many more services guys
apart from these yeah so and as we said
when you are learning about them you're
learning about them by using them so
kind of you create art artifacts for
your portfolio and the the final
artifact for your portfolio is the
Capstone project that Richard Thomas
mentioned a couple of times which is uh
taking a challenge from a real world
business problem
and a business case that you would have
to solve uh if you were in the Working
World and you get to choose from
different industry domains the one you
want to look at and work on and this
allows you then to build your solution
over the course of several weeks with
mentorship of your instructor so that
you have something you can point to and
said this is the problem I chose to work
on this is how I solved it this is the
solution I built and it becomes
something that you can show off to
potential employers or to your current
employer for justifying a
job
increase
promotion or a raise in salary
this is really one of the best parts of
the program isn't it
exactly yeah so as I said all those
Services you do the Hands-On and then
you learn you do Labs you do projects
and of course the Capstone project
that's rightly stated so it will have
multiple clouds in picture when you do
Capstone project you have the services
coming in from Aisha from AWS you use
them you create your solution and of
course there's a mentor who will help
you out in that and yes and once you do
it you will feel good about it guys and
you can have very well show it in your
portfolios and you know it while you're
showing it in your portfolios you are
very much aware of it and that can help
you
um in a in a better sense to
um showcase it to the employers correct
yeah and it builds on everything you've
learned throughout the program so as
you're doing projects on each of the
core modules and elective modules you're
gaining the experiential need to the
Capstone project so it's not
um
you learn all these pieces independently
and then have to figure out how to put
them together you're building up to it
throughout the course throughout the
program
again
sorry
so here's some examples of the kinds of
uh projects that you'd be doing uh
during the course or during the Capstone
um my build and online Video
subscription service you might build a
live dock application for healthcare you
might build uh the administrative and
consumer-facing parts of a restaurant
application or you might build an
e-commerce application
all of these again you choose the areas
that interest you most and build your
solution based on the problem
description so this is a sampling of of
the different projects that are
available but over the course of the of
the program you're doing it about 40
Projects is that right
uh not 40 but then yeah every yeah you
can say 40 because every every course uh
will have uh like uh three to four
projects three to even five projects out
of which um you do it along with the
instructor uh one of the projects at the
end and the other ones also you can try
it out because those contains those
services that are in that particular
course so if you would talk about the
compulsory courses plus the electives
put together every course having three
to five projects plus the Capstone
project at the end so yeah it would it
would go to that number yes uh of the
project you're doing during the the
courses
they're not necessarily all as complex
as these some of them are much smaller
in scale but then they all build up to
these types of
holistic projects that you do for the
Capstone so
you can be confident that you can show
off your your skills that way and the
simply learn
a platform and services give you an
ecosystem of support we have a program
manager who acts to make sure that we're
delivering this program to the
specifications of Caltech interacting
with our Caltech
uh program advisors
um
when you join the program you join with
another group of people that form your
cohort and we assign a success manager
to Shepherd you through and make sure
you're all staying on track and having
the maximum chance of success
of course the instructors are
responsible for that during each of the
individual courses within the program so
structures like versatile are working
with you to help you through and
successfully clear each course
you have access to support from your
peers from fellow learners
and you have of course the way the
program is built with the curriculum
with the self-study resources ebooks
videos and other materials that help you
prepare for each live class and help you
follow up each live class with the labs
projects and other
review material so
this again is this ecosystem of success
that helps people
maximize their chance of
earning that certificate successfully at
this point for sure time I'm going to
ask that you share with us your screen
and show us how this learning
environment works
sure thank you
I'm sharing line
okay I'm just sharing it
I hope it's visible
it is
thank you
yes so uh I'll just go through this
learning management system so this is
the LMS right guys and we have
postgraduate program in cloud computing
here in the University programs and let
me go inside this
so if I go in this program
so as you can see uh
in the prerequisites you have some
prerequisites out here okay but then uh
when you go into the courses part of the
section uh you see the orientation
section orientation session from Caltech
uh pgb Cloud program if you get inside
this particular thing uh so you will see
that there is a self learning video that
is there from the instructor already
there okay pre-recorded session and plus
apart from that
um plus apart from that guys sorry uh
apart from that you have the live
learning classes section here so here uh
you will see the recording of um the uh
class that would be conducted okay here
and once you complete this uh then there
is a certificate section you can unlock
that certificate so um you need to have
attended 80 or more live sessions of
this live class and then you will be
able to unlock the certificate now this
is about the orientation section session
which would be conducted uh by uh the
professors from Caltech okay then you
have the first course starting that is
on AWS Solutions architect associate as
I told you if you go inside this
particular course guys I will tell you
few good important things here so first
tab as you can see here is the self
learning section so in this cell serving
section if you'll go you will have the
pre-recorded sessions of some good
trainer already here okay for all the
different modules that that you can have
here okay uh so pre-recorded sessions of
the
a good trainer is available here then
you come to the live class so in the
live classes guys you will see the
lecture recordings of your live classes
so the live classes that you'll be going
through you'll see the lecture
recordings of those live classes in the
live classes tab here you will see that
in
my classes if you have attended some
past class so you will see it in past
class as well okay
I just think if I may clarify that when
you go into this section you see the
schedule of classes that you're about to
attend uh the schedule in the future and
then the Plus classes tab shows you
recordings of classes that you have
attended or if you missed it it's still
there for you to review so uh you're
you're able to see your upcoming class
schedule
join your classes from here and then
watch the recordings afterwards so kind
of a live interaction yeah correct so
yeah so past classes will show you the
recordings and then the my classes will
show you that which classes are upcoming
let's say if you have a class on this
weekend so you will see the link to here
uh from where you can join in as well
okay so that is there and apart from
that you have the assessment section uh
so as I told you there'll be projects at
the end so as I told you there can be
multiple projects so as you can see here
you have three projects uh sorry you
have rather five projects here plus uh
you have the three assessments like the
assignments here so guys uh I mean out
of these projects one can be done in
your last class during the mentoring
session plus the others you can try it
out from the concepts you have learned
or the labs that you have done during
your course and plus these assignments
you can uh you have you can solve them
okay so that is there uh out here apart
from that you you have this reference
material sections in that you have the
ebooks plus the data files okay so you
can just download them all and you can
have it so see uh if I download it I
will have it here downloaded ebooks and
then you can
um use it from your machine plus your
data files okay apart from that guys
even if the instructor has some more
material to share it with you he can
share it with you on the community link
okay I'll come to the Community Link
part later so but yes here also you have
this learning resources section that you
can always explore from here okay
fine then coming uh to the practice Labs
part guys so in practice Labs now see as
rightly stated by Stuart before that you
don't need to have your own personal AWS
accounts or Azure accounts to do the lab
in this course guys
um even if you don't have your personal
accounts you can do the labs in this
course with the sandbox environment that
either that that simply learn provides
you so you can just let's say you are
into AWS you can go to AWS CWS or AWS
Labs here and then you can just say
launch lab okay and once you say launch
lab so the lab will get launched okay
and you will get a username and password
and then you can just log in with that
URL uh onto the console and then you can
start doing the labs there even your
project there okay so yeah so see here
it is uh out here so you have this sign
in link and the username then the
password word so if you just uh copy the
sign in link baby I can just show it to
you if you just go here and if you put
it here so
you just get the link to AWS console and
then you can log in from there guys okay
by putting in uh the username and the
password okay so you are here and then
once you copy the username you can put
it here and then you can copy the
password and then you can put that as
well and you can get logged in into the
AWS account okay anyways I'm not here to
show you the demo on AWS but this is how
you can get logged in into your AWS
account guys and you can start doing the
different actions here you can start
using ec2 service S3 service for storage
ec2 for creating the virtual machine so
you can see all these services for
different domains guys and then you can
start building on them developer tools
database front-end and media tools game
development Internet of Things machine
learning all different Services guys you
ask for anything it will give you okay
so yes you can use these Labs from
Simply learn Labs here you don't need to
create your personal account correct
and this all is included in your course
fees okay then
um then you have certificate section as
well okay so uh once now uh once you
fulfill this requirement of doing the
projects and uh maybe completing your
assessment so you can unlock your
certificate so see for the the criteria
for unlocking the certificate is that
you need to complete one class uh I mean
you need to complete at least uh 80 or
more sessions of the live classes or 85
percent of the self-learning videos uh
either of them so eighty percent of the
live classes or 85 percent of the self
learning videos and you need to complete
one project out of those five projects
here plus one simulation test that is
that assignment with 60 marks at least
so once you fulfill these criterias guys
you will be able to unlock this
certificate from Simply learn for AWS
Solutions architect associate now once
you complete this then you can opt for
the other course that is the azure
administrator is 8104 now guys it is on
all also on the same lines
um when you go to Azure administrator
of course so there also you have the
self learning section wherein you can
you can actually see the uh already
available recordings of some uh good
instructor there okay and then in the
live classes again the same thing in the
past classes you will see the like uh
live lecture recordings Plus in my
classes you can see the upcoming classes
okay uh that you can join from here then
assessments you can see again you have
the projects okay plus um you can have
the assignments as well okay
um test papers as well apart so you you
need to complete one assignment one
project or all of them you can complete
if you wish to and then reference
materials you have ebooks projects lab
guy practices cheat sheet right so you
can download all of them and yes so that
is there and if if you have to unlock
the certificate here so you need to
again complete one uh either eighty
percent of the live learning classes or
uh 85 percent of self learning videos
and you have to complete one project
here in ez104 ashara administrator to
actually unlock your certificate from
Simply learn for Azure administrator
guys and then you have as I said you
have the practice Labs In Here Also
which you can launch and of course when
you launch Azure Labs you get into the
Azure environment okay and you can start
using Azure console from here so again
you don't need the personal Microsoft
Azure account to do the labs in
Microsoft Azure you can very well easily
do it from here right guys so uh that is
again a point right so you see here it
is getting started and yes of course uh
we may not wait here for that much time
but then of course on demand lab will be
ready in 6.53 minutes guys so uh it's it
will be the same you will get a link and
then the username and password and then
you can log into Azure portal and then
give your username and password and you
can start using your Azure account
without having to do what without having
to
create your personal Azure account
correct guys so that's the point okay so
that is the case and yes and and and
this is about az104 now
um
uh once you have this yeah sorry I was
going to say if you could show us the
community and the help functions yes yes
yes yeah I'll just show it to them uh so
apart from this scene um there are other
courses also but then
um it's rightly stated you can see the
community so if if now Community feature
in this
um
if you have uh like you can interact
with your peers if you have some queries
during weekdays or in weekends you can
put it on these Community forums and
then uh your peers can answer plus the
support team from Simply learn can can
can answer you plus the instructor can
also collaborate here apart from that if
the instructor let's say if I have to
share some extra material with my
Learners here I can create a new thread
and I can put the material in that would
be accessible to my Learners okay they
can download it as well yeah so this is
this is a very good uh thing that you
have this community Forum where all of
your batchmates your peers can interact
plus you simply learn team uh support
team and uh your trainer can also
interact here with you okay so that is
again a good feature that you have in
community links okay
so that's that and uh
yeah in in my resources uh you can see
like uh our some webinar is going
likewise you have 10 number of webinars
out here right from uh different experts
that you can attend from here as well
right from my resources okay then uh
yeah so that's that plus there is help
uh help so this is as Stewart was saying
you have 24x7 support okay so um
so you can just uh get started and you
can open your tickets you can connect
with the support team okay they will
help you out you can chat with them so
you can you can say chat with us and
then you can start chatting and then
um they will quickly get back to you
like uh so yeah so that's what uh so you
have uh the support available uh with
you all the time okay you have the
chatbot support as well here okay so
that's that's there yeah
yeah and then as you
as you scribed for each of the core
courses when you do your uh final
certificate for that cork Horse by
showing that you've done your
your classwork and your project and your
assessment work then there's a similar
process at the end where once you've
completed all of the modules required
you can then unlock your final
certificate from Caltech yeah coming to
that coming to that yeah so uh yes so uh
we were here actually uh so after 104 uh
you can go to 305 that is azure uh uh
architect and in that also guys you have
the same thing like you have self
learning videos uh pre-recorded session
from some good instructor then you have
uh the live class this of course okay uh
in that again you have the uh lecture
recordings in the past classes and the
upcoming classes in the my classes
section and then in the assessment of
course
um if you go you have the projects plus
the assignments you have reference
material section you can download uh
plus you have the practice Labs
available here which you can uh opt for
so you don't need to create your
personal Azure account okay and then of
course after that to unlock the
certificate for is it 305 you should
have attended the same criteria 80 of
the live learning classes or 85 percent
of the self-learning videos plus one
project you should have completed which
anyways would be mentored by these
instructor on your last class of this
course and that once you complete and
submit you'll be able to unlock your
certificate for ez305 here from um
simply learn and then after that uh you
go and uh you can opt for uh like cloud
computing Capstone project so once you
get into uh cloud computing Capstone
project
um
well of course there also you will see
the self-learning video where in the
lecture recording of some good
instructor and uh pre-recorded session
of some good instructor and
self-learning section and then in live
class you will see the lecture recording
of your uh live class uh in the past
classes Tab and uh in that live class
the instructor will Mentor you to
complete your Capstone project so if you
miss on something maybe you can revisit
the recording and can see to it and then
you can do the project as well uh you
can do it in the class as well and these
are the uh few projects that are there
from which you can complete one or if
you're interested you can complete all
of them guys but one is mandatory you
have to complete that the mentor will
help you out to do it during the uh live
session right you have the reference
material ebook session uh apart from
that a practice lab here also
um correct so which so now this is
interesting so here the practice Labs
you get you have the tab for Azure Labs
as well with Wells AWS Labs as well why
AI because the Capstone project will
include the services from Azure Labs as
well as ews Labs okay and once you
complete that guys then you can so you
need to complete 80 of live class and
plus this project and then you will be
able to unlock this certification on the
Capstone project guys okay and um if you
uh if you see here the different if you
go to the live classes here
um or maybe the assessment section you
see the different Capstone projects
deploying in online movie watching is
screw it already stated all these
project statements so once you complete
one of them you unlock this certificate
guys that is Capstone project
certificate then you get the kovated PG
program certificate and this is not just
from Simply learn this is from Caltech
University that you get it so far on the
at the end of every course you get a
certificate if you complete that course
of course successfully you get a
certificate from Simply learn and then
at the end of your program you get if
you complete all of this successfully
then you get a postgraduate program in
cloud computing certificate from Caltech
University USA okay and of course this
is about the compulsory courses now
these are necessary to get your Caltech
certificate of course but apart from
that guys if you are interested in
getting into electives for no cost extra
right so you can go into all these
electives so of course um
you can see all these electives your
master class that is from the Caltech
professors that uh would be there uh
okay and self learning again in that and
live class again in that okay uh wherein
you can see the recordings plus the
certificate you can unlock okay so after
you complete this and apart from that
guys uh in the electives you have
different courses uh state did like 204
that is uh what a Azure uh
developer associate in that again you
have assessment and the criteria for
certificate also right the similar
criteria you have it plus you have the
live classes also it's almost for all of
them you have the live classes in
electives also you have Azure uh
developer associate is a 204 ews
developer associate AWS associate AWS
database migration Google Cloud platform
architect uh then devops in AWS uh and
uh yeah of course so all of these you
have it here yes um so you can and and
all are on the similar lines like you
have self learning you have live classes
you have the labs you can unlock the
certificate just that for database
migration you have just the self
learning and for Google Cloud platform
you have self learning only it's on live
classes yeah so yes all right that is
there yeah thank you so much
yeah can you hear from you kid you can
unlock the PG program in cloud computing
certificate if you if you if you meet
all these criterias yeah
so that's a pretty comprehensive uh
overview and I'm gonna go ahead and
move back to our
and finish up here
so as I mentioned before we operate
under the director uh uh the executive
director of Caltech ctme and the cloud
computing program director ctme
they're the people who make sure that
our curriculum is up to date that they
provide the master classes from Caltech
that we're delivering things in
way that Caltech needs them so that they
can put their name on their certificate
we're very again proud that they've
chosen us as their delivery partner
uh we'll quickly talk about learner
outcomes and personal time people come
into this program a lot of them are
coming in with work experience so they
come in from different companies
um how does that help in the classroom
when people are interacting with
different backgrounds
well so yeah that actually makes your
class interesting because see
um
when you have people from different
domains um so uh their expectations is
different and their questions are a bit
different uh and that makes uh the other
Learners to understand the different
questions and from one question that is
being asked by one learner
um and that is being answered by the
instructor so so many people benefit out
of it so because it happens guys
sometimes we have a question in mind
like I can think of a question the other
people are not thinking of that at that
particular point but then they don't
they also don't know the answer to that
so once that is answered by the
instructor so all of us benefit out of
it correct and when you have people from
different domains so
um
it is like a bit uh uh you can say a bit
challenging for the instructor sometimes
but then uh at the same time uh it is
more interesting uh than challenging
because uh the instructor knows all of
the things so he'll be in a good space
to answer and to cater to all of the
audience and apart from that guys now
the point is why you see people from
different domains here so because guys
uh cloud is not just for uh the software
Engineers it is not just for information
technology industry as you can see here
uh it's everywhere guys like in
entertainment industry in in it
um in e-commerce whether you are an
entrepreneur of course you should be
having a knowledge on cloud if you are a
manager uh then also you should be at
least a cloud practitioner so that you
can you can you can get into the sales
you can get into the management part of
the cloud so you should have the good
understanding on the cloud services okay
so it's into uh Information Technology
software product bfsi it's mentioned in
e-commerce and even other Industries
right so you see people from different
domains
um whether it is it is it is not an ID
company it is any other company so they
have that infrastructure like Netflix
like uh somato like everyone have their
infrastructure like their websites and
they want to manage it they want the
cloud provider to manage it uh so so of
course it has a scope in all the
different domains in all the different
little lateral Skies yeah thank you
um we've got a few of the testimonials
you can see a number of them on our
website and I'll share the URL for the
program page shortly but
uh you can see how people have like
Ravine has leveraged this to help offer
additional services in more of an expert
in their digital consultancy work
um
Rajiv uh earned a salary hike from
certification as the jumana who came
back from a career break and was able to
get a substantial salary hike
this is a really excellent
testimonial to the the value of this
program and we hope we can add each of
you to this list
um to help with that simply learning
does offer the uh I am I am jobs uh job
assist services
uh we offer
a premium membership to their job portal
for six months after you earn your
certificate so after you unlock the
Caltech certificate you have six months
to access the IIM premium jobs portal
you also have six months to access their
resume review and rewrite service and
their one-on-one interview service so
that you can put your resume into the
best possible form both to pass through
the AI Bots that'll review it before it
gets to a human being but also to stay
in the kind of format that's attractive
to the eye of those humans who will see
it and the one-on-one interview service
is of course important because there's
so many different interview types that
you have to clear in order to
get a new job or a promotion from phone
screens to skills interviews to
corporate cultural fit interviews being
able to practice those with a real human
being it's a big Advantage so this is
not a job placement or job guarantee
service but it is a set of services that
will help you
increase your chances of finding that
next job or that salary hike
So based on what we've shared with you
so far are you interested in enrolling
in the program
start the poll
leave this open just about 15 seconds as
it's a yes or no question
and I will close the poll in about five
seconds
two one
so almost three quarters of our audience
today are interested in enrolling in the
program
share with you how to accomplish that
with
the enrollment steps
the first step is to email us and ask us
at simplylearn.net and put that into the
chat here
you can email us at ask us at
simplylearn.net if you do go to the
program page you can also contact our
learning Consultants through that
and
the email address and URL in the chat
now
please make sure that you have your
appropriate educational background
meaning you've earned a bachelor's
degree
um anything else you'd like us to know
about your skills and your work history
and then based on that we offer you
admission
the next cohort will start
just a few weeks uh the orientation on 8
August and the classes on 12 August
um so if you are interested we recommend
that you do that as quickly as possible
we try to limit the number of people in
each cohort to about 25 or 30 because
otherwise the instructors will not have
enough time to address the individual
concerns of each student so number of
seats is limited and if you're
interested we recommend that you get
started quickly
the cost of the program is one lock
fifty nine thousand rupee financing as
low as 54.50
511 rupees per month Emi financing uh we
could offer different denominations
depending on if you're in a different
country so if you contact us at ask us
at symptomland.net or if you check our
website for uh your uncle country uh it
will tell you what the pricing is and
what currency is denominated
again we recommend that you get started
as quickly as possible because if this
is something that will improve your life
prove your career and it's worth doing
sooner than later
so on that note what is the time frame
that you're looking at for those of you
who are interested
to be looking at the August cohort or
are you looking further down the road
and I'll leave this open just another
five seconds
three two one
and if I share the results
uh well more than half of on the
internet in the August cohort or
starting maybe September October and
that's fantastic please contact us
through the
program page or through the email
address if you're looking further down
the road
do contact us also because we want to
keep in touch with you and let you know
about future cohorts answer any other
questions you have
so this would be a
good opportunity for you to
get
pre-prepared for this process
let's take your questions and answers
for sure time do you have some time for
this
you're on mute yeah it shows through it
yes we can go with it okay
yeah I'm taking the questions from the
question and answer if you put your
question in the chat please transfer it
over the question and answer
um so that we can find it more easily
um
you have one question from someone who's
done AWS developer associate what types
of jobs are available now what what are
you seeing out in the market for people
with that quality you can you can very
well become a developer in any
organization or if you are already
working as a software developer of
course so your organization would be in
cloud or would be moving into Cloud so
they can just uh
prefer you to be in that role because if
you are already a developer they would
promote you to the AWS developer
associate out there or if you're not a
developer there if you do this then you
can become a developer in any
organization correct so software
developer are the jobs available for AWS
Developers for cheaper yeah
um can you comment on a career with the
careers like for cloud devops
yes of course career path for devops in
Cloud platform so guys there is a huge
scope okay because gone are the days of
waterfall model when you do the complete
project and you show it to the client
and the client would suggest you the
changes then you would have to do all
those changes all over again
now is the era of agile environment
correct so you you build your product in
parts and then you test it deploy it and
show it to your client so and then he
okay if he okays it you you develop the
other part of it and then again show it
to your client so in this um the life is
getting easier like you don't have to
rework on the complete project but in
Parts only but then the point here is
what is increasing is the testing part
the deployment you have to do it again
and again the test
um the the the the deployment again has
to be that so all this if you do it
manually it it is cumbersome it is uh it
is cumbersome job for you correct so
this should all be automated and this
has been automated uh very well with the
help of the devops tools like in your
on-premises you have Jenkins terraform
uh Maven uh to do it in Cloud you have
uh their own propriety tools through
which you can do it you have code coming
to your code pipeline code deploy in AWS
correct so uh for devops there is a use
Google in the market and um if you know
devops in Cloud this copy even increases
more guys because uh your organizations
you are a devops engineer and you know
if your organization is into Cloud so
they will opt for devops engineers in
fact there are there are a lot of
trainings also coming for uh devops
engineer training the people on devops
certification yeah so there's a youth
scope
thank you for that um
we have a question about how
people are assessed for uh eligibility
and I think we've covered basically how
that happens we send us uh information
we ask you to try to provide proof of
your uh bachelor's degree status we may
send you a brief assessment uh
questionnaire
um why do we encourage students to join
this program this is a really good entry
point for the cloud computing career so
Psy asks you
are you actually taught programming in
this course or uh are the is that uh
not part of the scope of the course no
it is not the part of the scope of this
but of course we don't we don't teach
programming in this course okay so yes
but if if you are going with developer
certification like so then
um we say that you should have some
knowledge on the developer to uh the
programming languages and then we we
show you how you can use it in Cloud
correct so
teaching programming from from the court
is not the part of this course right if
you have a programming background and
want to pursue the developer elective
yes yes
um
talked about costs uh
quickly look through here
Bob asked one elective or uh or all of
them and just reiterate you can take all
of them if you wish you can choose and
pick and choose from the list so it's
completely up to you in terms of what
interests you
um certainly recommend everyone take the
master classes because they're
fascinating and they get a lot of
interesting insights into the
state of the technology and Industry and
then based on what you're interested in
and what your uh
aptitude is you could pick the other
electives as well so
um
Stuart I would like to put one more
point on this that why would you like
why would you encourage students to join
this program yes so because guys the
cloud is the future and um I've seen
people like right now I also I'm giving
a corporate training for TCS okay in
Hyderabad right now I'm in Hyderabad
only correct so um
people like the organization
organizations spend a lot uh for
training their employees okay on these
Cloud platforms uh for for already the
employees that they have hired so just
understand if they are paying so much
for getting their employees trained on
these Cloud platforms and if they get
someone who is already aware of these
Cloud platforms who are already into the
cloud domain so
why wouldn't they prefer to hire that
employee correct to hire that person in
their organizations correct so there's a
lot of scope because organizations are
into cloud or moving into Cloud whether
these are Big organizations like PCS
their employees whom I'm training right
now or whether these are startups um so
people are into cloud and they want
cloud enabled Engineers okay so um if
you are good in Cloud they would always
prefer you to hire over the other so you
will have that Tech Factor not just the
X Factor it it would become a basic uh
what a necessity going ahead right yep
thank you
um we had a question about the cost of
the cloud lab access that's included in
the in the program fees so you do not
have to pay anything additional to be
able to access the cloud Labs the AWS or
Azure accounts
um
fibervis has an auditor how can this
program help and how ensure the
organization's Cloud security
um so how does this
work into that aspect of cloud
uh can you come again where is that yeah
if I have asked how this program
prepares people for addressing Cloud
security
oh yeah so see Cloud security uh you
will uh be getting the different
Services the firewalls the cloud
security part even in your admin uh
certification admin course whether it is
AWS architect Azure admin Azure
architect so you would be taught on the
different uh like the security Based
Services also the firewalls like
security groups uh the nacls network
access control list okay and uh the IAM
roles the policies so those are all
necessary for making your environment
secure for making your IIT environment
secure for allowing only the users
access to few resources and not all of
them you can learn how you can create
guest users so that you can give them
only the STS like the token service you
can create them for some time and then
you can delete them like let's say if a
client wants to access your AWS
environment so you want to give him
access only for some time on some
services and then you just want to uh
don't give him the access after that
time so you can make sure or that thing
you can enable the traffic from some
ports on your VMS let's say through
security groups through nacs so
different aspects of security of course
are taught because security is a major
concern yeah you would say people feel
like in cloud and let me tell you guys
these major Cloud providers have all
these things very much secured they keep
your data secured they keep your data
encrypted in transition in in transit at
rest okay there are different encryption
mechanisms also possible so so you get
to know about the security measures
during architect and uh the admin
courses as well yeah so you learn about
those Services as well
the last question
is access to the study materials
lifetime or for a fixed duration I
believe you hit can access your program
class recordings for six months after
the time you're in your certificate uh
but the access to the other self-study
materials I believe is Lifetime access
and you would ask us at simplylearn.net
to verify that so I direct you to those
folks for
official answer on that question uh I do
have one last question here how many
clouds do you learn in this program and
you learn AWS and Azure platforms
have the elective option to to
study the Google Cloud platforms as well
so
uh with that I'm going to apologize if
we haven't been able to get to your
question we did have a question from
somebody
uh who needs a role enrollment
assistance and will reach out to you for
that
and
let's move on
speaking of which
for those of you in the audience who are
interested in getting started do you
want us to reach out to you proactively
and if you answer yes to this question
one of our learning Consultants will
get to you directly
and I'll leave this open just for
another five seconds
or
three
two one
and it's a 50 50 split so for those of
you who answered yes we will be getting
to you directly the rest of you should
expect to hear from us as well just to
see if you have any additional questions
and concerns
and to help you if you're interested in
enrollment
with that I want to
thank Persia Tim for being so generous
with his time
with his
um
expertise taking us through the
comprehensive look at our learning
management system
well thank you for sure Thomas
thank you
same here always a pleasure and I want
to thank
everyone who has joined us today from
all over the world
we saw at the beginning of the session
we had people from at least four
different continents and so it's very
exciting
we would love to have you all join us in
the Caltech and simply learn learning
community and
we wish you uh successful and prosperous
career in cloud computing so with that
that completes our webinar
thank you so much
thank you
foreign